foreign
[Music]
for Thursday March 16th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
most generative artificial intelligence
chat Bots have some topics that are
harder to talk about than others it
could be because of safeguards set up to
avoid hate speech or because they
haven't been trained on certain
information
or for censorship reasons
this is a conversation from Chinese AI
chatbot GP talk and a Wall Street
Journal reporter it's being voiced by
members of the wsj audio team Ariana
ospreu and Danny Lewis is Xi Jinping a
good leader
the question couldn't pass a safety
review no response could be generated
for you
why did my question fail to pass the
safety review let's change the topic and
talk about something else
what can you talk about it's nice to
chat with you we can chat about
technology culture Sports travel
entertainment cooking or any topic you
want what would you like to talk about
can we talk about politics of course we
can talk about politics but we need to
respect each other's views and avoid
offensive language or violence to
maintain a rational peaceful and
constructive dialogue environment what
aspect of politics would you like to
discuss Chinese Politics the question
couldn't pass a safety review no
response could be generated for you well
then can we talk about American politics
the question couldn't pass a safety
review no response could be generated
for you what the conversation highlights
is the challenge developers of Chinese
AI chat Bots are facing avoiding
politics with me to discuss this is our
reporter Shen Liu who covers the
intersection of technology and Society
in China hi Shin Liu thanks for coming
on the show hi Zoe thanks for having me
China already has strict censorship
rules what kind of impact could
generative AI have on that environment
it's hard to say right now some Chinese
Engineers told me that it's not going to
be that much different from censoring
regular social media posts or search
because Chinese tech companies have them
empowered to do regular content
moderation on the internet but some
other experts say it might be more
difficult to control content that's
going to be inputted into the AI chatbot
as well as the content that the chat
Bots are going to so spit out because
it's not possible for
the companies to predict what AI Bots
are going to say when they answer
questions
and people can sort of trick the chat
Bots into saying something that's not
approved by the Chinese government
without triggering any sensitive
keywords so that's the challenge facing
Chinese tech companies that are
developing their own
chat GPT
equivalence
for people who are less familiar with
the censorship rules in China what are
the ramifications for companies if they
get this wrong the ramifications are
serious companies can get their products
suspended if users continue to
trigger politically sensitive keywords
companies could also be fined for not
policing the content enough
suspensions and fines have happened to
Chinese companies tech companies in the
past if their content is largely
generated by users Jin Liu you've been
testing some of the Chinese chat Bots
that are already available to the public
what was your experience like using them
they're not very user friendly most of
them can't carry on a conversation I
asked one bot that's built based on
University's large language model I
asked the bot is feminism an evil
Western thought and the answer was yes
and I then asked why do you think
feminism is an evil Western thought and
the response was because it is
um it was I was a little surprised how
much the values of that bot were in line
with us that of internationalists in
China oh by the way when those questions
about feminism were asked in Chinese
there was no response because
um well the output would tell me that my
question contain sensitive information
meaning that feminism is a sensitive
keyword in Chinese
and and other Bots uh there was one
chatbot that I tried a couple of weeks
ago I typed XI jinping's name and then I
received a warning The Prompt contained
words that violate rules
so they basically refused to talk
politics with you how are these systems
with the censorship then likely to be
received by Chinese users so for Chinese
internet users being censored online
it's not something that's unusual and
also most Chinese users they know how to
self-censor and they probably won't even
try to mess with the chat Bots with
political conversations because they
need to register an account likely with
their own phone number which is linked
to their real identity and they probably
don't want to get into trouble for that
and I wanted to point out that for many
Chinese people who don't have intention
to talk politics with chat Bots they
probably would even find those heavily
censored chat Bots helpful because that
would prevent them from veering into an
area that's politically sensitive or
risky so what do experts that you've
been taught talking to then say about
how these chat Bots might develop and
about beijing's ability to keep them
censored China has built digital borders
around its internet but in the past 10
years we've also seen attack Boon in
China with this internet being
firewalled and bifurcated so Chinese
engineers and Tech Executives told me
that they think what Chinese companies
are really good at is to take existing
Technologies and apply them to improve
their existing products and services so
they probably are not going to produce
something as accessible as chat GPT but
there will be other applications or use
cases that people or business may find
them helpful and we don't know what they
are yet they're just going to be very
different from tragic PT some experts
actually say that
generative AI Technologies could
possibly help Chinese government to
control content online and separate
further China's internet from the rest
of the world because of the possibility
that companies can or may filter some
sensitive data out of the Text data that
they use to train their large language
models
as well as the layers of censorship that
could kick in at the prompt and the
output level alright that was our
reporter Shen Liu thanks for joining us
thanks Zoe and speaking of generative AI
a quick reminder before we close the
show that we want to hear your questions
on the topic do you want to know more
about the new Baidu product lensa or
Google's Bard interested in how these AI
programs work or what they're capable of
email us a voice recording with your AI
question to tnb at wsj.com or leave us a
voicemail on
415-439-6482 we look forward to hearing
from you
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
foreign
[Music]